[Música]
vamos a hablar de salud con más Romero
salamaro Buen día para usted Buenos días
Ángela un tema que seguramente les dará
esperanzas a muchas personas hay un
último Avance en la investigación sobre
el dolor crónico sí efectivamente es muy
esperanzador y muy informativo también
se trata de la investigación de un
equipo estadounidense que publicó sus
resultados en natury que lograron hacer
un mapeo digamos de cerebro de pacientes
de dolor crónico lo que hicieron fue
implantar con cirugía unos electrodos en
dos regiones del cerebro solamente en
cuatro personas por lo tanto también
tener en cuenta que es un estudio de
dimensiones muy pequeñas todavía estos
sensores los implantaron en dos zonas
del cerebro en la llamada corteza
singulada anterior que es la que está en
azul en el gráfico y en Amarillo la
corteza orbito frontal que son dos zonas
que están relacionadas con La regulación
de conductas social sobre todo también
con la toma de decisiones o con el
procesamiento de sensaciones como la
sorpresa o como el miedo y gracias a
esto lo que pudieron hacer es monitorear
la actividad cerebral de estas personas
durante su día a día no que los
pacientes vayan al laboratorio tomen un
escáner o tomen estos estudios sino que
a lo largo de sus días de su
cotidianidad puedan ver cómo funciona el
cerebro y especialmente en esos momentos
en los que aparece el dolor crónico
gracias a estos datos encontraron varias
cosas primero y es importante que los
circuitos cerebrales de cada uno eran
distintos no cada paciente tenía su
propia huella Digamos como experimentaba
en el cerebro su dolor segundo que se
podía predecir y esta quizás de la parte
más importante el dolor gracias a los
sensores sobre todo en la zona amarilla
en esta corteza orbitofrontal y también
pues pudieron concluir que realmente son
circuitos muy distintos los del dolor
crónico a los del dolor puntual es decir
no mueven las mismas cosas en nuestro
cerebro cuando te quemas por ejemplo al
algo muy caliente que este dolor
crónico que aqueja tantas personas bueno
Cuál es la importancia que pueden tener
estos resultados para la vida práctica
de las personas pues para la vida
práctica probablemente todavía falte
mucho pero si es un primer paso hacia
una investigación más en profundidad de
una dolencia no también es importante
poder evaluar este dolor de formas
objetivas con estos marcadores con estos
sensores que no solo sean percepción
subjetiva que es como normalmente se
suele medir el dolor crónico y que
entraña pues algunas dificultades A la
hora de comprender bien la experiencia
de una persona también abre la puerta
posibles tratamientos si estos sensores
que se pueden implantar sirven para
medir porque no pueden servir para
regular no es un poco la pregunta de los
investigadores que igual Pues por
supuesto faltará mucha investigación por
recorrer aquí y pues motivar más
investigación En cuál es esta función de
la corteza árbitro frontal De esta zona
que veíamos en esta regulación o en este
procesamiento del dolor crónico además
es importante decir que toda
investigación sobre esta dolencia es
bienvenida falta mucho por comprender
algo que además es muy complejo en el
cerebro siempre es difícil entender Qué
sucede pero es una dolencia muy
extendida el dolor crónico que se
entiende Como un dolor que persiste por
más de tres meses a pesar de tomar
medicación afecta entre un 18 y un 34%
de la población es muchísimo a pesar de
que es difícil entenderlo precisamente
por esa valoración subjetiva de la que
estábamos hablando sigue siendo la
principal causa de incapacidad en el
mundo y tiene una carga de enfermedad
altísima y en adultos mayores la
prevalencia puede llegar a superar el
50% es decir que está muy extendido
también importante las implicaciones
sociales sabemos que el dolor crónico en
Estados Unidos y en muchos lugares es la
puerta de entrada por ejemplo a tomar
opioides no a tomar medicamentos que
regulen el dolor crónico que ayuden con
eso Y a partir de aquí pues ya sabemos
todos ya conocemos la crisis que eso
puede desencadenar si no se trata bien
No claro y este tema que cómo siente el
dolor de uno a diez es absolutamente es
muy difícil de explicar y también hay
muchas personas que tienen problemas
para comunicarse no que no tienen una
comunicación fluida y que ahí también
puede ser muy complejo entonces hacerse
entender Y que todos sentimos dolor de
diferente manera vamos a hacer un cambio
de tema pfizer ha dado noticias sobre un
potencial farmaco para la pérdida de
peso esto es absolutamente po Ya lo
hemos hablado antes con otros
medicamentos y sus consecuencias Qué
pasa en el caso de pfizer sí le vamos
dando seguimiento porque parece que son
unas un tipo de medicamentos que están
ganando mucha popularidad últimamente en
este caso vuelve a ser un medicamento
inicialmente pensado para la diabetes y
la farmacéutica está intentando ver si
se puede pues renovar Digamos como un
medicamento para perder peso según el
estudio que se publicó que es un estudio
en fase dos es decir que todavía
faltaría uno antes de la
comercialización se dieron varias dosis
distintas a los pacientes y en las dosis
más altas la de 80 miligramos y la de
120 miligramos vieron que sí tenía un
efecto diferente respecto a las personas
que estaban tomando placebo Es decir que
sí las personas estaban perdiendo peso a
raíz de tomar este medicamento al cabo
de 16 semanas aproximadamente es decir
unos 4 meses las personas que tomaban 80
miligramos habían perdido unos dos
kilogramos de peso las personas que
estaban tomando la dosis más alta de 120
miligramos más de 4 kilogramos de peso
perdidos en cuatro meses estos
resultados los ponen en un lugar
parecido a los fármacos que ya hemos
hablado aquí de Nuevo norte es como
wiggobi o como sempic que ya se están
comercializando para perder peso no Y la
diferencia En cambio es que la opción de
pfizer son unas pastillas orales pero
funcionan de una forma muy parecida que
al final es un medicamento para
controlar el azúcar en sangre diseñado
al menos inicialmente para eso también
tiene el efecto de suprimir el apetito a
partir de ahí es que se produce la
pérdida de peso pero también importante
decir que hay unos efectos secundarios
de los que pfizer tampoco escapa que son
náuseas vómitos o diarreas porque de
todo el tránsito intestinal digamos que
se ve afectado por tomar este
medicamento No pues es que todos
aspiramos a bajar el azúcar en la sangre
pero no de una manera repentina y sin
Ver las consecuencias más adelante pero
parece a pesar de todo que estos
medicamentos están de moda mar están
arriesgadamente de moda por decirlo de
forma suave Ángela la verdad las
farmacéuticas están A toda máquina
desarrollando medicamentos parecidos a
estos porque se cree que en 10 años Este
mercado el mercado de las fármacos para
perder peso puede mover unos 100.000
millones de dólares en la próxima década
Entonces digamos que hay aproximadamente
una decena de farmacéuticas entre ellas
pfizer nuevo nordis el y Lily que están
corriendo para poder hacerse no con una
parte de Este mercado pues tan cuantioso
y tan apetitoso también para una empresa
como una farmacéutica no esto sucede
además después de haber visto el éxito
que está teniendo
esta popularizando a través de redes
sociales de personas famosas que lo
están tomando para perder peso de forma
rápida solo ayer para poner un ejemplo
las acciones de pfizer subieron un 4%
después de que se vieran no los
resultados positivos que estaba dando
positivos para ellos que estaba dando su
medicamento sabemos Además de eso que va
a dar mucho dinero porque vivimos en un
mundo al final donde clasificamos a las
personas a través del índice de masa
corporal no sobrepeso obesidad asumiendo
entonces según En qué categoría que haya
esa persona si es una persona está sana
o está enferma y también hay un un curso
muy extendido que en esta sección de
salud siempre hemos intentado
problematizar alrededor de que el
sobrepeso en Sí ya es una enfermedad y
que al ser una enfermedad debe ser
tratada no esta es la concepción general
que existe hoy en día y por lo tanto un
medicamento que pueda tratar una
enfermedad cuando lo entendemos así pues
por supuesto va a ser muy popular no
entonces Bueno aquí está el problema
vamos a ver qué sigue pasando y como
siempre por supuesto lo vamos a ir
explicando aquí y ojo con caer en
capitalizar el sufrimiento de las
personas y la gordofobia como siempre
Gracias mar Muchas gracias Ángela